a new president has taken the oath of
office in Zimbabwe but is he any
different from the old one my guest here
in London is Nick mang Juana
the UK representative of the country's
ruling Zanu PF party with 35 years of
bloodshed on their hands massive
corruption and an economy in ruins what
business have they got continuing to
govern
[Music]
Nick my one and welcome to complex on
thank you Tim don't bother me we have
your new president saying that he was
inaugurating a new democracy this is a
man who in 37 years has shown no
inclination to promote democracy in any
form whatsoever what's to suggest that
he's going to change now I think that's
what we're correct Tim to say that he
didn't show any inclination from a
democracy what we're talking about here
is a man that has been a speak of
parliament who showed an even handedness
and Parliament's for the time being for
the time he was one we're talking here
of a man that lost elections and was
happy talks up the results therefrom
we're talking of a man who's been
individually named and sanctioned by the
EU first in 2002 when the European
Council expressed serious concerns among
human rights violations by the
government of Zimbabwe among 273 other
people absolutely collective
responsibility the school councils ban
was extended in 2004 and 2009 they
accused him mr. Managua as a member of
the government of engaging in activities
that seriously undermine democracy
respect for human rights and the rule of
law seriously undermined democracy that
doesn't sound so good for the future
does it that's that's EU / lens which
would have been applied to any Zimbabwe
needed him and we are talking 273
members of the establishment so you are
basically saying that this bobbing army
there all of this moment military forces
should because the top Iraqi were all
there well you are saying the
bureaucrats you are saying the general
is that with him we're undermining
democracy no that's not correct what's
what so everybody else got it wrong we
you got it wrong the US which also
sanctioned him got it right everybody
they work in tandem
no you were so misunderstood that's
incorrect
the point I'm making is yes they were
human rights violations that's that's
goes without saying and yes when
National Building but yes we have taken
responsibility
was week went and put in place a new
constitution because nobody's been
brought to justice
because our Constitution well we have a
new Act which is coming place of
national reconciliation where these all
these matters will be dealt with so if
you already yeah national healing yes
that's also gonna deal with the most
serious allegations made against mr.
Managua which came in a 2002 UN report
to the Security Council it called him
the key strategist of an elite group
involved in illicit diamond trading have
you read that I read that report and
that report is full of contained
innuendo ignore facts whatsoever they
were simply calling him the beggar man
if you ready go for an investigation
what investigation
the UN's of these allegations what's
allegations that you have the bottom
involvement of the report the networks
which he was a senior figure in made
money through what they called a variety
of criminal activities including theft
embezzlement diversion of public funds
and evaluation of goods smuggling force
invoicing non-payment of taxes kickbacks
to public officials and bribery here we
feared read letter put is you want to
pretend you did you return okay okay
there's no specific there's no specific
that's worth investigating
it's what I'm saying it's not our
responsibility used to use money to
investigate things that have happened in
the Congo when it's not as well as the
money the combo if they lost any money
because the accusations are from
minagawa they are mounting
multiple corporations there are many
governments our Guinness mannequin
so let me get mr. Manawa do you expect
Zimbabweans nevermind the international
community simply to gloss over all this
instead of seeking a detailed accounting
of what took place or don't you care or
don't you simply don't care or don't you
see there are hospitals which are which
mr. Managua were indeed in the generals
are being through a mean I've been
fitted with they've been fitted with
rose petals right now they are heroes
including the generals they are talking
about in all way involved in all these
things that they are talking about
so it means mobiles are happy with the
situation the people that are not happy
is you oh really
yeah we're happy let's talk about the
public theater of the last 10 days -
yeah Mr Mugabe wasn't pushed out in
order to bring in democracy was he
silent PF had been perfectly happy
trashing democracy for 35 years the
thing that brought change was the
terrible realization that Mr Mugabe was
going to bring his wife into the top job
and that would have upset all the vested
interests in your country people had
counted on managua coming in to protect
their interests and their secrets no
risk that so correct what people could
not risk is somebody won't they thought
would to be unstable in who appeared and
behaved in a stable way to take over the
controls of power in Zimbabwe it would
disturb lies it wouldn't disturb lies
the whole country it would live to serve
as the region that was the concern
that's not the view of didymus what has
a veteran of the liberation struggle he
was close to Mugabe for 50 years he was
quickly the army intervened he said to
save zanu-pf
not the country he is a member of the
Opposition who also is what vested
interests in the matter
he's wrong he says the armed forces in
central his opinions in the Arab inner
he says the armed forces are made up of
zanu-pf members he said not Democrats
intent on ushering in a pluralistic
system not Democrats intent on assuring
in so in other words forget about
democracy no is a better said old man
that's what I'm saying this was working
for democracy let's forget about what
remember over she would say again I say
no but they go on saying that but
nobody's fooled avec even at the
swearing-in ceremony there were people
who weren't taken in look at them look
at the president of Botswana for one in
karma he said it pretty clearly I don't
see why I should wish him Mugabe well if
he cared nothing for his own people why
should I care for him and then there
were the crowds that booed the police
commissioner general Augustin Chihuly
and the calls for him to step down you
think every you you talk about rose
petals for everybody rose petals at all
this I'm sure you didn't you didn't
actually check the relationship between
the people of Zimbabwe and the
Commissioner general the generals the
rest of the army or the rest of the city
else secure secure Kratz and the general
ending and we to worry why do you think
the police were made to stood to stand
down why are they only the right now as
I'm talking to you starting trained
patrol patrols with the army because the
police were not trusted by the people
they were not trusted by the army they
were not trusted by the sub they were
trusted by only President Mugabe why
because the person that was second in
command of the police is his cousin and
and the war point was to safeguard that
presidents mr. what is disturbing to
many people seems to be in your country
there are plenty of science that the new
president is no different from the old
one
you take his warning about pluralism and
political opposition those who oppose us
will bark and bark he said they will
continue to bark but the zanu-pf train
will roll on ruling and ruling while
they bark a misinterpretation of what
action that's a direct quote of what you
say yes but I would tell you any courts
get taken out of his context it loses
its meaning you think this man is ever
going to allow the barking dogs of the
opposition to sweep him out of power
you know if they win not a chance if
they win he would if they really would
it's when uses the backing a phrase it's
not only about opposition into it even
included grace what you are simply
saying is when I'm focused on something
I'm like I'm like a train or a
locomotive
every job which runs around alongside
the tricks can bark and back but the
locomotive does not stop it's called the
locomotive is not the country it's
zanu-pf as far as his career core
Fortran it was transformation within the
country its trash we made me six tracks
democracy which actually we did trash
them across / - yes we made mistakes and
yes we messed up they could mistake
nearly disaster whatever whatever line
you tow and you're a very friendly guy
you're a nice jovial sort of fun
whatever line you tow you know full well
that mr. Managua is hostage to the
brutality of the brutal record of
zanu-pf theory his period as head of
Central Intelligence in the mid-1980s
coincided with the most brutal of all
Mugabe x' massacres didn't so-called
kakora
only killings in which up to 20,000 from
the underbelly tribe were killed or
disappeared he's denied any role but
actually the state-controlled Bulawayo
Chronicle reported at the time that he
compared dissidents to bugs and
cockroaches that had reached such an
epidemic that the government needed to
bring indeed lay out your things get rid
of the edge of things yeah I hear I had
you now give me a chance to respond to
you first the thing is we were in a very
very formative years of our country
mistakes were made
I've an excuse his massacre it doesn't
excuse him we're not making excuses I'm
simply saying we made mistakes so that's
an admission that we made mistakes
that's number one number two during that
period when he was minutes or security
Yeek was coming to Palam in to account
for his actions all the time with a very
robust filament at that time crimes this
was these weren't talking offences for
which you go to call and pay a fine this
was murder on a grand scale
there were mr. Howlett mistakes is the
biggest understatement in history mr.
Mahina
not mistakes it's not Hitler made
mistakes did he Stalin made mistake no
they were mass murderers this was mass
we most would diminish it no we're not a
minister no we
Lawson we lost people we lost
Zimbabweans and for UK i lost from 82
it's unfortunate that it happened but in
the formative years of any nation if we
go back to the history of Britain we
would find that there were pages there
were people that died it does not it
doesn't it doesn't clear people it
doesn't make it any better but the fact
still remain in a formative years of a
nation things who happened when the -
should not have happened
mr. violence is stamped into your
party's DNA and that's already been
proved yet again in the last week the
very day the new president was sworn in
the former Finance Minister Ignatius
Trumbo was handed over to the police by
the military who had beaten him up
severely and while he was held in
custody and in depth amia choosing where
to testimonies Tombo Ignatius Trimble
mr. Minister talking about vision in
this transmission
john-boy himself in his testimony in
chief he never said he was it was a
serum you know he was tortured he then
the activist lawyer is wrong because the
actual person didn't allege and
investigate University this refers to
fight in court Webb will fight the court
records isn't it when when somebody says
to place under oath that's what we go by
and so are we making it up as his lawyer
said it was a very brutal and Jacobean
way of dealing with opponents if he says
that's that's I can accept myself for
his life a couple of weeks ago I don't
accept you calling me and my countrymen
Standish
but I would say that it was it was
unconventional it was wrong it shouldn't
have up into that way but we were not
thanks and you know right before you is
not sitting attack isn't it time that
you came out and admitted what's been
going on in your country all these years
apart from just trying to get out of it
by calling it a few mistakes
now and admitted that people deserve
something better than zanu-pf okay
people know people deserve what they've
worked for exactly that's what that's
what democracy about is if people are
choosing zanu-pf then they deserve some
opf isn't it
are you going to prescribe leaders
personal for person for the people of
Zimbabwe they've made a choice they'll
make a choice in July or so they'll make
a choice again they chose done appeal
that's what they deserve
I put it to choice Maduro who was
miyabi's vice president for 10 years
yeah yeah that under Mugabe Zimbabwe
became a byword for corruption murder
atrocities and torture she didn't argue
with that she didn't know she said it's
a fact
what's known okayed when you quit
opposition was but she was with him for
10 years yeah but then vice president
but then but then if you haven't said
sorry for any of these murders in
corruption atrocities your torch
corruption is there and it's a problem
there you go I've made an admission made
us not to the scale you want to say
things happiness I told you in 1980
which shouldn't be in the 1980s which
shouldn't have happened
there you go you love those
understatement things happen
no these were murders and massacres that
were carried out this was brutal brutal
violence and things when I'm saying
playing it down well they were there
were tourists way I mean there were
dissidents just 1 2 there were tourists
who actually kidnapped and killed they
were they were somewhat egde of
infrastructure there were very election
violence around the point thousand a I'm
explaining what I mean by things
happened so the response to their
response to that was disproportionate
yes and I ended that's why I'm saying
things happened because things happen on
both sides and that's the phrase I think
is easy would not raise temperatures and
ethnic tension in Zimbabwe exactly I
think what you're trying to do in
January on the voice of America you were
asked why your party hadn't been more
successful in improving lives for the
majority of
yes three and a half decades and you
replied it's a matter of time it's not
gonna happen overnight
of course yeah seven years and you say
it's a matter of time same with people
spitting this theta 7 years mantra they
behave they they pretend that there's
nothing good happened in Zimbabwe when
when rural electrification went around
when people went they were educated
people when schools were built when
provincial hospitals and rural hospitals
were built when University only started
with one university now with what 16
things positive things happens it's such
a wastage this is the venires you see
but as for the economy yes you certainly
my Wanger
yes yeah I'm sorry certainly sent
records but they weren't the records you
wanted under your party's grotesque
mismanagement inflation peaked around
3,000 e at 231 million percent
congratulations thank you very much you
hold that record but why because you the
West and the mind awake oh it's it's the
West so forth staggering income of
course waiting copy to the way the
ineptitude as well I give you that but
let's not let's not completely dismiss
they wrote the substance plate because
the whole point was to bring down the
suburban economy and it's bad the
suburban government and it worked to
some extent but the only thing that
didn't happen is the government also
brought down ministration now is running
at more than 14% industrial output is
less than 10% of GDP compared to 25% in
1990 nobody's under 18 they were to work
before the new president it's a lot of
work in the trust which he has to embark
on right now that's why I say they I
have to hit the ground running and they
first top government official to make
this admission we know as vice president
he went to China and he made the
admission that symbol was 20 years
behind in development and and when
somebody of that stature in that level
makes that admission it's a very
important admission and because of that
is not underrating the test before him
there are plenty of sorry
that your public wants justice and these
last few days plenty of Zimbabweans have
been speaking out because they feel
they're able to t know Martha small
business owner in Harare he reacted
pretty badly to the news that Mugabe and
his family have already secured immunity
from prosecution he said why do people
think that once a crook is out it's now
okay for them to keep their empire why
even bother overthrowing them if we're
not going to reclaim money and assets
could Zion bad zou made working in one
of the wealthy suburbs she said let them
live peacefully in Zimbabwe but they
must find out how much they have if it's
a lot maybe take off forward Missouri
torero one of your party officials
Mugabe should be prosecuted and sent to
jail for a long time he said if I meet
him one day I'll give him a blow in the
street he squandered my livelihood you
really think people are gonna accept
this immunity up to the people but I can
tell you this that M our Constitution
does not grant immunity post incumbents
so President Mugabe was immune to
prosecution when he was in office now
how the new government will process this
whole thing or Gazette this immunity is
something else because edom it's only
binding in s far is their own goodwill
and the gentleman the gentleman Liz Ness
is concerned he's already been told that
he can keep his assets he and his family
and get at least 10 million Georgia
romba Mugabe's principal told The Times
newspaper last week that the
ex-president had been assured his assets
were secured and which assets are those
okay
they own a day they're the largest
landowners in the country they own a
deadly to private schools they control
the running of an orphanage they own a
twenty five bedroom house in Harare
known as the blue roof along with a
second property in the same city and a
three-story home in the country they
have a 2.4 million house in the Sandton
suburb of Johannesburg
an apartment in Hong Kong and a room and
also to have property and in Malaysia
and Singapore not bad not bad
but and no consultation on this shoddy
little deal that allows him there every
now be beyond the law
what precedent that says the union
theocracy did you did you really want a
referendum on that
oh this thing was negotiated up and
celebrate they didn't care they didn't
mind what it was they wanted to move on
with our lives
democracy talk of new democracy wealthy
when no one is Bo so do you think
democracies bloodthirstiness in the
Indian in definitiveness as well as a
retribution it's not if you're talking
of restoration yes you are talking about
something else but not you're not the
type of democracy where you think well
let's go back and and read in Iraq
temperatures and then let's not have any
justice no what's your definition of
justice team what's the definition
justice brought to account for massive
fraud and crimes ax man and people are
being brought to account who well you
raise the defense minister Maccabi yeah
we're raising the finance minister a few
minutes ago what about the man who run
the show
well demented the man who run the show
unfortunately well fortunately for him
but Zimbabwe needed to move on and we
indeed this was the best solution
circumstance team whipped cream with a
short video that the MDC if ever a
referendum on this I will tell you it
isn't it that's the whole essence of
having a Constitutional Court with nine
judges prime judges who can who can
overturn it if it's unconstitutional
let's go that's the whole point that's
the whole point of having institutions
which are independent and I what you
dish out is independent Grace Mugabe she
gets
$75,000 a year for life Wednesday do you
think that's fair do you think you think
that you think ever in a pension is
wrong think she paid tax on any NGO do
you have any problem with people getting
pension I didn't see dollars in the
country Constitution because of our
Constitution says those things should
happen when when the president is office
or in a vice president leaves office if
they've served attempt it is one time
showed a little deals how do you have a
diversion from a constitution no I don't
understand of my Constitution
and that's what they off that's the oath
even the President to to upper hold it
that's Constitution so I'm not ashamed
of what course you said is one of the
best in the world and we'll read it very
highly
if the elections take place next year
yeah as their showed you to do so your
party can hardly campaign on its record
Kenneth thirty-seven years of corruption
thirty-seven years of blood on its hand
and now this deal this immunity deal
presumably to buy Mr Mugabe silence
because he has capabilities did you take
a lot of look at what have filtered I've
told you that we have got more than 60
percent outreach and coverage in
electricity I've told you everything
else that we have done I've told you
about the illiteracy rate I've told you
about the hospitals were built we've got
a lot to combine for I will told it will
reset old people we worked a lot to
combine with but not human rights no
human rights oh yeah we X for me now we
have a lot to improve on that twenty we
have a lot to improve unless it's will
be lent you the MDC has got violence to
you know the best president when the MDC
was charged a few a few weeks ago
Oh ambassador when she was in the MDC
ambassadors in ago when she was in the
MDC she was bashed again married mate
honks it's unfortunate that we've got a
coach of Iranians around us would you
want to eradicate and whoever did this
violence during this period give us big
give us some credit from the theta from
the 14th with Amina wind up to this
point
whoever they didn't incidents of
violence this man wanna 37 years of
credit thanks very much for being on
conflict so thank you for having me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]